I know you're about to release your
second book but I wanted to ask you
about your first book Church was was
that in 2013 2013 released make your
story really stinking big through
Michael we see productions and it was
funny because when I got to LA I was I
didn't go to film school so I had to
self educate myself and so Michael we
see productions like I loved their line
of film books primarily because or at
least initially because they have the
best covers and I'm like a graphic
design guy so I like like nice cool
covers I was attracted to the line of
books and loved the line of books and
then when I decided to publish my book I
I was going to self publish it but just
decided on a whim to send it to them and
they end up picking it up right away and
published through that and so that was
kind of cool but yeah that was 2013
release okay and so where were you in
your life when you decided to write it
and where would you find the spare time
sure
so in when I first decided to write that
book was we were we were really me and
me and my team and the guys I was hooked
up with we're trying to figure out how
to best tell stories that touched
multiple mediums and multiple platforms
how do we extend the story across the
multitude of mediums in a way where it
all works together from news to form a
new experience with the audience and and
I actually you know I was I I didn't
realize it at the time but I brought
some of this with me even from law
school I I produced a I produced a film
while I was in law school and it was
this just a you know it's like a 25
minute short and I as the film was being
produced I wrote and produced I didn't
direct it and as it was being produced I
had an original song produced
simultaneously for the film what was
interesting about the film was the the
protagonist of the film only has a
couple lines during the the entire films
just very he doesn't speak hardly at all
he's very much like just that's
internally kind of a guy so for the song
when I was working with the songwriter
for the song I thought well this was
gonna be a great way to get inside the
characters head so now the song is gonna
release these internal thoughts that you
don't hear obviously we're know
about when you watch the movie so now
the song and the movie will go together
in this really interesting way then I
thought you know be really cool when we
do the music video if we can use the
same sets that you know as we're
produced in the film we can just either
before we we film a scene or after we
film a scene before we strike we can
just put the musician in their film the
the music video send that then it's the
same looking aesthetic as the as the
movie then I thought would be kind of
cool is if we had the actors also in the
scenes as well it's like if they were
blocking a scene then we could have you
know them in there and that kind of give
it its interesting look and then I
thought okay well if we can shoot the
entire scene the scenes from the movie
maybe from a different angle in the
music video when you watch the music
video you're going to get new
information that you don't get from the
movie so now when you watch the music
video and the movie together it's going
to give you this full thing made my
director go crazy as you can imagine but
I brought that type of thinking with me
out here you know I grew up very much
into Star Wars he-man GI Joe
transformers these multi-platform
projects and so I I've always had a sort
of a taste for that so when we got here
and I tried to do it it was very
difficult it you would think okay come
up with a board game thing come up with
a mobile game an app a comic book that
I'll tie in together wouldn't wouldn't
be that hard but to have it to do that
well is very difficult and we failed a
couple times and we learned a lot of
lessons so I put I hit the pause button
and went on about a two-year research
project looking in every great
multi-platform project that I could find
every very poor multi-platform project I
could find and again used my lawyer
super abilities to forensic ly audit the
creative choices that they made the
business choices that made why did the
Goodwin succeed why did the bad ones
fail and I was looking for me just a
creative rubric to of how to move
forward for me just for me and you know
and being the genius that I am I decided
to do all the things like the good ones
did and not do the ones that the bad
ones did and so I formed a creative
process I guess a creative rubric that
that she was just really for me and my
own projects and the team's projects but
I decided hey this would be kind of a
cool book again I'm trying to figure out
how to differentiate myself in the in
the marketplace from all the other
competitive people and I thought if I've
created something that works for me
other people that are trying to solve
this problem would benefit from this and
so that's when I published the book so
so you know at the same time I was you
know I was doing legal consulting while
I was out here I was working with not as
a lawyer but with lawyers and how to
best present their best presented their
arguments to a jury how to incorporate
more storytelling how to incorporate
diamond dynamic visuals things like that
and basically trying to help like
produce their courtroom performance in
an interesting way while I was doing
that I was writing the book and then
when I wrote the book really all I
wanted it to be was a business like a
big fat business card for me but once
the book was released then other people
started calling me who read the book
like Mattel called me and said hey we
read your book we want you to come in
and talk about a project the Disney
Imagineers say hey we you know we want
you to come talk about it which is
something I never considered I was just
doing this for me and my own projects
but that sort of opened opened me up to
so there's a whole of the realm of of
work which was great when you're stuck
in a full-time job have other options
that are closer to where you want to be
is always exciting and new and and
different then working with other people
in their projects help me on my own
projects because then you just start to
build a facility of diagnosing problems
coming up with quick prescriptions for
those problems and you kind of sharpen
that tool so then when you get your own
projects it's very efficient
you